I want to chime in about a new tour date
we have in Austin we have added a
another show there Sunday June 11th at 7
p.m at the Bass Concert Hall and we will
be there I'll also be in Edmonton
Alberta July 14th Guilford
New Hampshire Gilford July 20th Windsor
Ontario August 18 Niagara
Falls Niagara
I don't want to say that I want to
upset any people August 20th and Toronto
Ontario Toronto sorry August 27th get
all your tickets at theovan.com
t-o-u-r we've got some new merch items
to tell you about the be good to
yourself crew neck in teal
it's frosty and we got the new hoodie in
Bittersweet plus we've got the root beer
T-shirts from the uh root beer cartoon
all that and more at Theo Vons store.com
hey guys I'm in the West Village of New
York City today and uh I am met my
friend Keat she is a
um entrepreneur she has a beautiful
coffee shop and uh flowery or uh Floral
shop called Rosecrans and she let us use
this vintage carriage house today
to record in so very grateful to her if
you want to support her or some of her
businesses in uh The Village in New York
City you can check her out at ad hoc
Collective and we are very grateful for
this beautiful space that we get to
record in today
today's guest is a journalist he's a
public speaker he's a New York Times
best-selling author who creates works
that often deal with what makes us human
how stories and and facts overlap he has
his own podcast revisionist history
which goes down some really unique
rabbit holes you'll hear a little bit
about that today
um I'm grateful to have in one of the
most unique minds of our time and they
get to spend some time with him today's
guest is Malcolm Gladwell
[Music]
shine
people and I will find a song
[Applause]
thanks for being here man I don't know
yes thank you uh we met years ago
briefly uh it was a coffee shop in Los
Angeles
um yeah it was called top of Montana
maybe or some there was a coffee shop on
Montana Avenue over in like uh Brentwood
yeah in Brentwood
yeah I remember seeing you there and uh
I was like and I wanted to ask you about
I mean I was just thinking like man it
would be crazy if one day I got to talk
with Malcolm Gladwell yeah so I used to
hang out at uh
uh Cafe Luxe in the Brentwood Country
Mart oh yeah maybe that's nice oh it
wasn't there though no it wasn't there I
made a rare oh I know what you're
talking about yeah yeah uh it's changed
names
I knew exactly what you mean yeah I used
to go there in the morning yeah yeah
it's a fun place everyone sits outside
yep everyone sits outside and some
people have dogs and stuff and sometimes
they even give away dogs there they'll
have like a little one of those candles
or like like a kennel will come they're
like you want these dogs yeah yeah it
used to be a
Coffee Works or something no then they
have some funny name now yeah I like
that place a lot yeah it was cool but I
remember seeing you man I was so excited
so really awesome to be able to get to
chat with you today
um
yeah I was uh
I was thinking like one thing about you
that's unique is your hair
well the same could be said of you yeah
we are people you know a friend of mine
once said
they're only a handful of people in
history who are recognizable in profile
like in you know a black and white
simple you know Mickey Mouse
uh you know this is like a short very
short list he's like you have the
potential to be recognizable in profile
um well do you feel like it does
something for you like yeah it's
interesting like I think if I am gonna
go buy a book right
um especially from like a smart guy
right like um I kind of there's
something in me that wants that guy to
look smart
well you're telling me I look smart
I think to me it would be my perception
there's but I don't know if I thought
that if I know that you look smart
because I've read some of your books and
I think that you're smart yeah or is it
because it's the forehead it's not the
hair uh I don't know I don't know
there's a whole there's actually this is
true or not but maybe someone read
somewhere or someone was telling me
people do
falsely but nonetheless it's a
stereotype about people with big
foreheads I have a very high
forehead and it slopes back I have my
mom's forehead people think that means I
have a big
brain I don't think it does I think I
just have a high forehead it slopes back
but I think people you look at a big
forehead and you think whoa there's
something in there there's something in
there yeah that guy's got a guy's got a
Hemi in there guys got a V6 yeah yeah I
could see yeah I guess maybe I could see
that but I think there is something you
want the guy
to look us so you kind of want the guy
to look smart
yeah well the other thing that's going
on hair wise is
people with big hair like mine got lucky
with Einstein
oh Einstein set the template for the big
crazy hair being associated with genius
right before Einstein if you ask someone
to imagine a genius they would never
have imagined someone with a head of
frizzy hair there was no association
there Einstein is like the kind of
template for this idea that you know
this he has a joke he is a Jew fro not
an afro but you know the idea that a fro
is somehow symbolic of
craziness yeah yeah he does he's almost
got that fact fro yeah froze he's got
facts in it you know or did he give you
that he does have awesome hair you can I
mean Einstein is the most brilliantly
kind of branded Genius of all time yeah
right but also since we're on a subject
you know Beethoven also crazy hair so
maybe it goes back a little further not
quite as magnificent as Einstein but
when you picture Beethoven in your mind
you do picture like this shock
of hair that sort of symbolizes his
intellectual turmoil
yeah I think yeah well it seems like
yeah his hair seems like there's a he's
just like it's there's so much going on
it's Gotta Get out of me somehow yeah
you know what do you think your hair
symbolizes
um
well I noticed for me I noticed once I
grew my hair I had my hair long when I
was young yeah and then I tried a little
bit more to like assimilate kind of I
feel like when I whenever I moved to Los
Angeles and I had my hair short I think
I was trying to you know audition for
sitcoms and different things and then
once I grew my hair long again I just
felt I just felt like myself yeah I felt
a lot more human
um
one time somebody
there was a uh somebody cut the back of
my hair off like on purpose they did it
without me knowing a barber
um
like in like a vindictive way and
and I didn't realize it until later and
if I felt like dehumanized even like I
felt I mean that's the word but I felt
almost felt like when Native Americans
when they would take the other person's
scalp it made me think of that like I
felt like they
I don't know I feel like your hair it
really has something to do with you you
know yeah well you're you're channeling
a little Patrick Swayze at the moment oh
that's a good point yeah yeah that's
what I'm thinking about probably
non-cancerous you know because I think
he probably had I think he had but he
smoked a lot I think yeah I don't know
about his yes I just I'm thinking that
or you could eat you or like a really
fun you know metal band from from the
70s yeah that's the other right those
are good associations by the way yeah no
it feels good yeah no I don't feel like
it's I feel like it's a warm judgment
you know yeah
um but yeah I just thought about that I
was like oh Malcolm has interesting hair
his hair makes me believe that he is
smart is there like does his hair mean
anything to him does it did he like pick
it up from somewhere because my hair
does make me feel like a lot more
comfortable as myself yeah um I don't
some people call my hair a mullet
haircut I don't think of it like that I
just think of this is how I feel most
comfortable and this feels
um and it feels like your hair it's like
a it's an expression of you kind of it's
like
you know it almost picks up signals I
think some people or I don't know if
this is true or not I might just be
saying this and think that it's true but
like it's like some animals have like
little hair on them and it makes it
picks up information
do you think that's
well I've always had you know I had my
mom's hair my mom is uh black so I have
uh a version of her hair and um I've
historically my hair is short at the
moment it's been much longer
um when I was a kid it was much longer
and
um I think I liked it because it was
very you know I grew up in an area that
did not have a lot of was very very kind
of white very there was very little
curly hair going on where I grew up yeah
and I think I sort of liked the idea
that
um I stood out a little bit Yeah seemed
kind of I think that was the main
attraction of it was just it was an
element of difference
yeah I can relate to that I grew up in
an area that had like a lot of clean
there was well there were some people
that had like real clean hair like their
hair looked like
when they slept at when they were asleep
at night their hair was also asleep
whereas I've always felt like yeah my
like nothing inside of me has ever
gotten a moment of rest really yeah I've
always felt like even when I'm laying
down like the rest of me is just
frenetically trying to just survive in
the world so I think
um I remember seeing some people and
their hair just look so comfortable I
was like God dang boy that's nice you
know like their hair look like it's stay
like you know like it just
um it looked like it had conditioner
just built into it you know well I don't
uh do anything to my hair so I don't
comb it
I don't even with like shampoo or you
just use water just water yeah I mean
it's it is the most kind of I don't even
pay any attention to it it just sort of
is yeah and then every now and again I
get it cut
um and don't it just it kind of exists
um
yeah I was just thinking about that
because a lot of your book I read your
book I read your or one of the uh
talking with strangers oh yeah yeah
talking with strangers that's the one
that I read
um and I didn't think I was going to be
able to really read it and then I mean I
knew I would but it was just like I
didn't know if I'd have the time and
then I just it was cool it was enjoyable
it was it was interesting it was easy to
read
um one thing that I found fascinating in
it like well how would you kind of
summarize like what the book is sort of
about like just kind of briefly just so
people can know and then I had a couple
of kind of things out there were
interesting
well it's a book that tries to figure
out why so many of our interactions with
strangers go wrong
um and because I was struck when I was
writing it by how many of the sort of
stories in the news were stories about
uh
you know
Bernie Madoff the famous Ponzi schemer
is a guy that everyone who invested with
him they thought they knew who he was
and they were all wrong yeah uh I just
tell a story about a spy in that book
who
everyone thought they were a loyal
American and they weren't the female
right yeah yeah uh Montez yeah um that
was unbelievable yeah she's like one of
the one of the most damaging spies in
American history and she's just like
she's you know she's sitting there doing
her job for 10 years and no one has the
slightest inkling that she might be
working she's working for the Cubans the
whole time not even her and her sister
and her brother she had she had a
brother-in-law who worked for the FBI no
sorry her sister worked for the FBI and
uh and was oblivious to this yeah that
blew my mind yeah there but they were
you know and there's I tell stories
about you know um
Jerry Sandusky that uh Infamous
pedophile oh yeah stayed in you know
he's he's he's he's in that job for 25
years and like everyone thinks he's just
this lovely guy you know and so I was I
was really fascinated by
that idea that
that
um you can meet somebody and you can
completely Miss
so much of misunderstand so much of what
makes them tick
um and why would we be that way you
would think as human beings that we
would be
that Evolution would have favored those
who were good at figuring out strangers
but it hasn't the opposite is true right
here we are the most out of the the
finest point of our Evolution and we're
terrible at this fundamental task and so
that's that was the kind of puzzle the
book tries to unravel yeah yeah and it
based it kind of on the Sandra what was
that Sandra Sandra Bland yeah Chandra
Bland it was a case where an officer
pulled a woman over
and then they ended up getting into an
altercation which almost seems like it
shouldn't have happened yeah
um and then they arrest the woman she
ends up in jail and I'm just kind of
like summarizing obviously and then she
takes her own life yeah it was one of
the more one of the one of the more kind
of remember there were that string of
cases yeah right around the kind of Rise
of the black lives matter movement about
African Americans being
having these kind of lethal encounters
with police officers and hers was one of
the most high profile and
um what was crazy about that one was
said
the because the officers uh
he's got a video camera the entire time
we have we know exactly what happened
between the two of them yeah and he fun
he meets someone
she runs us
she rolls through a stop sign he pulls
her over and he becomes convinced really
early on that she's up to no good she's
got drugs she's something and she's not
any of those things she's just unhappy
and he reads all of her
signals of unhappiness as signals of
threat and dangerousness
and so he like he gets her wrong right
and so the question is why does it get
her wrong how can here's a she's a young
woman she's driven a long way to go for
a job interview her life has not been
going well she's trying to start over
and still town in Texas
and she's had some mental health issues
in the past but not insurmountable ones
but she's just someone who's going
through a lot yeah and this cop pulls
her over and convinces she's a criminal
who's got a gun and maybe drugs and
could potentially harm him
like that's there's a big difference
between unhappy and being potentially
violent dangerous and so my question is
how does a police officer who you would
think would be good at that right
being able to distinguish
threat from unhappiness yeah
um how did he get and so why I use that
case as the way into the book right
which is this let's use this to try and
figure out why we're bad at this yeah I
loved it I really like I didn't like I
loved kind of like I didn't know about
that I wasn't familiar with that case
right obviously I'm familiar with like a
lot of interactions that you see where
uh with police and black people you know
it's it's a pretty common kind of a
current set yeah you know where there's
a lot of fear there's a lot of
uncertainty
um
it's funny because when I watch the
video because then I because then it led
me then I went and watched the video
online and it felt to me like
yeah the policeman took some offense to
what she did yeah it took some offense
to some
behavior of hers I don't know if he felt
like she was like uh dismissive of him
or
you know immediately on trusting which
has to kind of also suck for a police
officer if you are a most trusting guy
you come up and you're con and then
everybody's always just like you're
untrustworthy yeah
um
well he he's way too quick to jump to a
conclusion about her and that's what it
seemed a little high strung yeah and she
also seemed High Strung yeah and so it's
interesting because also we had um we
had a police officer on a while back and
uh he was saying the mo the the number
one cause of death amongst police
officers is suicide yes it's incredibly
stressful profession unbelie it's like
so it's the the whole into the whole
thing is all it's just it's all
interesting that what a stressful job
it's like and then you have her who's a
strat who's obviously dealing with a lot
of stress and stuff in her own life and
so then you have this meeting of
just I mean it's it's a lot to put on
the fact that somebody just rolled a
stops you know it's like yeah something
that's not that severe yeah
um I mean a lot of that has to do I
concluded was is about time you know the
problem is that he's rushing
and if you're he rushes to a conclusion
he rushes to kind of deal with her he
rushes to find out what she's all about
he jumps to a judgment about her and you
know the those are when you're rushing
the risk of making an error just goes up
dramatically and his it's a you know
that's one of the lessons I take away
from the book which is the getting
people right
requires an enormous amount of patience
um and
um we have to particularly
a job high stress high stakes job like
policing we have to build patients into
these kinds of situations you know teach
police officers that you don't have to
resolve this in
two minutes you know right you can you
pull her over or you take some time to
get to know she is before you know we're
not gonna you're not on the clock by the
way
many police officers are on the clock
that's part of the problem that they
have supervisors who are measuring their
productivity and say you've got to
resolve every encounter within that's an
incredible mistake
um doctors are the same way you go to
the doctor doctors are on the clock it's
one of the reasons why they get things
wrong they don't listen to you is that
they've got
10 patients at the door and an
expectation they have to get through all
10 in the next you know that's that that
idea we confuse we get so obsessed with
productivity in many things that we
sacrifice the kind of uh uh the accuracy
and the meaningfulness of the encounter
yeah that's a great way to say it
exciting news uh we have a new sponsor
for our show and that's Caldera lab
you know you can say goodbye to the
generic face wash on your counter
because Caldera lab is here to save the
day when it comes to your skin
backed by Leading clinical trials where
nine out of ten men
experienced healthier and visibly
improved skin Caldera lab has the tools
to unlock your best first impression
you know you got to take care of your
skin and I've been using Caldera lab and
I like it
it makes me
it's masculine but it's
God it makes me feel like I'm taking
care of my armor that God gave me that's
why so many men trust Caldera lab
for their skin care needs use code Theo
at
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com for 20 off their
best products
the Clean Slate is where you start your
day it's a balancing cleanser
it uses gentle plant-based cleansing
like rubbing on just a sweet Garden on
your face
leaving all skin types exceptionally
refreshed
they also have the base layer and the
good the good it's that go-to at night
before bed prep yourself for sweet
dreams to show up looking perfect
get 20 off with our code Theo at Caldera
lab.com that's 20 off at calderalab.com
by using Code Theo unlock your youthful
glow and be ready for summer with
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-l-a-b.com use code Theo
cold turkey
people say it a lot
but there's a better way to break your
habits than cold turkey
we're not talking about some strange
voodoo or a hex or something
or some tick tock
we're talking about our sponsor fume
and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit
fume is an Innovative
award-nominated device that does just
that instead of electronics fume is
completely natural
instead of vapor fume uses flavored air
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses all natural delicious flavors
I like them baby I like them fume boy
um
I like them
oh you will too stopping is something we
all put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fuma served over 100
000 customers and has thousands of
success stories join fume and
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today
head to try fume try fum.com and use
code Theo to save 10 off when you get
the journey pack today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save an additional 10 off your order
today yeah I would totally agree I think
um it's almost a it's a micro look at of
kind of larger Pro things that are going
on in our entire Society you know yeah
that there's not enough
long-term even a moment doesn't have the
long the longevity that it feels like it
used to have yeah you know I talk a lot
about how I don't even think a mo like
you don't every moment is captured now
you know so it's like a moment you used
to have this Whimsical value that it was
like you can't ever replicate it it's
like you know
um it's like a flash of lightning you
know well it's like and that's why there
was so much value like in storytelling
and things because somebody was like man
you're never gonna believe this like
this is what happened and then now we
capture every moment you know and we
watch them so many times that it's
um the value of something you something
used to never be able to be replicated
and now it's everything is so
replicatable yeah audible this reminds
me of I did a podcast an episode of my
podcast revisions history a couple years
back on uh I stumbled on totally by
accident I met this guy who's a
investigator works with police
departments to investigate uh police
shootings and
he's I was at his
house for someone office for some other
reason and he showed me this tape and
it's a tape of
uh cops a guy steals a car cops follow
him at high speed they finally get him
pull him over he gets out of his car and
they shoot him all these times right and
you watch the you hear about it and you
wash the tape the first time
and you think oh my God it's another one
of these cases where the gun down this
innocent guy who didn't you know and
then he
walked me through we had the video of
the whole thing he sits me down and he
walks me through the video frame by
frame by frame by frame and he proves
that actually it's not what you think
this was a guy who had all kinds of
mental health problems and he wanted the
police to kill him that's a it's a
well-known phenomenon of death by cop
where somebody does something and is
willing his own and he's like you don't
catch it
the first time you watch this video
you've you've got to slow it down break
it down frame by frame have some context
about the case and then you realize it's
a hundred percent the opposite of what I
thought the guy is
as they shoot him he's going he's trying
to get him to shoot him more when they
don't like and you watch it he breaks
and he shows you like what's going on
and it was this incredibly you know it's
a it's not people don't want to hear
that interpretation sometimes
um but it was I just remember I was
sitting I drove all the way to hit an
office outside of San Antonio Texas
middle of nowhere it's really
interesting guy not a guy I would
normally ever meet or hang out with yeah
his world is very different from mine
and he just sat me down I just remember
him saying I gotta show you this video
it was one of my favorite episodes of of
I've done of my podcast I just thought
it was like
and the way I told the story was
we started out and you know I wanted the
audience to reach the first to jump to
the conclusion that oh this is an
innocent guy being shot by the cops and
then slowly you kind of peel off the
layers of the onion yeah and then you
realize oh my God I got it wrong yeah
right it was like a kind of I always
remember that it was like it was like it
was one of those cases where
if you ever had this where you're trying
to tell a story and you think it's going
to be really complicated you sit down
with one person
40 minutes and you think oh my God
that's it that's that's it that's the
whole story like I don't need to do
anything else I just need to like
run this thing as it happened to me but
it was very memorable day well a lot of
your a lot of the talking with strangers
was was kind of like what you just kind
of described you know there was a lot of
things where I was like wow I I'm amazed
that that wasn't seen by people I'm
amazed how like sh like
how
people would get a certain moment wrong
how some people like you talked about
like defaulting a truth a lot of times
people want to believe the person so
yeah that's like a natural way that
um a lot of things like that are bad or
kind of wrong or off continue to go
because there's just a human nature for
us to default to believe or want to
believe yeah
um I found a lot of that stuff really
really fascinating about the story
um and then I liked how in the end it
just comes back to this case of this
officer and this woman right
and also when I was watching the officer
and the woman in that tape there was
something about
when the woman started smoking you know
I wonder if that like of because I think
with police there's like probably an
expectation that things go a certain way
yeah you know
um so I wonder if that like offended the
officer or something like you know you
just don't know sometimes
because even though we can't have an
idea of everything it still comes down
also to that there's two people who have
had their their own unique lives up into
that moment you know
um yeah I think he thought that her
smoking was kind of that there was
something
dismissive and also slightly Sinister
about it like you know that he because
he had in his head that she might be a
potential bad guy right
drugs guns something do you think that
like or I I didn't read all the case I
didn't see yeah I mean I don't know I
think you know he's he he's
got a variety of kind of scenarios in
his head when he stops her and one of
them is
she's running drugs and she's armed oh
wow and I think so I think any police
officer who
when you stop someone you will you
always have in your head a scenario
where they're a bad person I see right
not just because not because she was
black just because of any person just
scared like you've got to think I'm
stomping them I'm you know
as a police officer when you approach a
car yeah uh you you know you are running
the risk that they're armed and they
might shoot you right that's a good
point so they're saying he's so he's got
that in his car he's got 10 different
scenarios in his head and one of them is
that probably yeah and he and the fact
that she's smoking I think he kind of
that adds Credence to the one of the
scenarios that says that she's a kind of
a
weirdo yeah something's not not right or
something why would she start selling
the war fan or something yeah
midnight walk you know minute and I get
there she smokes starts smoking like
it's just I don't know he just sort of
he's categorizing her as that there's
something off with her something wrong
with her and that adds to that
expectation I think
yeah I think I kind of took it as like
this seems like kind of like a white cop
kind of guy so I start to generalize in
my head they kind of have a and all
police officers I think have a certain
way that they kind of expect things to
go like they get an understanding of
this is how things go when you stop
someone you know you tell them what's
going on they comply really to a certain
way and then everybody goes on about
their business based kind of upon what
the cop decides how things should go
yeah right so I think I to me it seemed
like the some of the ladies actions like
yeah and the smoking kind of conflicted
with that
um
but it was real just going back into
your book and along this kind of same
thread one of the things that really
stood out to me was about how judges and
machines like if you put the information
like if you put people before a judge in
a court
um
that the judge who you think would be
able to interpret what the like a lot
more information by seeing the person
listening to the case
God they
they got it wrong more than the machine
did is that the right way to say it the
so if if I simply give you the so the
question is Europe you've been arrested
and the judge has to decide whether to
let you out on parole yeah yeah I have
and that's no I mean I'm talking
hypothetically oh yeah yeah sorry but um
yes the so the judge has to make a
prediction about you and the question is
how good is the prediction right and a
lot rise in that prediction if you go
out and commit another crime the judge
looks bad uh that's why they cut
people's hair and shave them and put
them in a suit and exactly it's about
that perception so the question is
I could just summarize on paper
all of the things about you where you
live how old you are nature of your
crime whether you've been arrested
before a Buddha
feed them into a computer or an AI
system right and have them have the
computer make a prediction or I can give
the same information to the judge and
say meet the person so you're giving the
judge more information you're allowing
the judge to look at all the information
the computer looks at plus whatever
information they can glean from the face
and facing encounter and the question is
is the judge better at making that
prediction
um because they have access to more
information the information they can
gather from a face-to-face encounter and
the answer is no they're worse wow in
other words meeting somebody makes you
worse at predicting what they're going
to be doing then so it brings into
question all kinds of things like do job
interviews this is another thing by the
way I've been obsessed with with my
podcast versions history I we've done a
we did a show on job interviews and the
truth is that like there's not a lot of
evidence that in a job interview meeting
the person
helps right and I did a funny thing
where I interviewed
I've been hiring assistants for 20 years
so I went back to all my old assistants
and I had them tell the story of how I
hired them and because I don't believe
in job interviews I hire them in the
most kind of random way I'm like you
know I don't even bother asking
questions I don't ask them I make a rule
of never asking them where they went to
school the I thought it was funny it was
a funny episode because I was
interviewing all those and I had
forgotten like how totally random my
hiring practices are and by the way I've
never had a mistake only actually only
once said I hire someone who didn't work
out and they left within two weeks I'm
still in touch with most of my one of my
old assistants is like one of the most
trusted employees at my podcast company
oh that's awesome my point is it's just
not you could pretend yeah it's sitting
down and talking to somebody for half an
hour will help you make a meaningful
judgment about what kind of person they
are but you can't it's nonsense so you
might as well my point is I just roll
the dice what the hell yeah most people
can most people if they're all I'm
interested in is
if they applied for the job they're
clearly interested in working for you
they showed up on time so I don't know
they seem reasonably you know they're
like I'm actually I try to be nice to my
assistant and if you're nice to people
they usually work hard so like I I pick
people who've got a college education so
I know they've know something about the
world that's all I need why don't need
anything else yeah you know yeah it's
interesting I've found my producers for
pop for podcasts and I found them like
like the one of the first guys just a
random dude just emailed me like hey man
I can do the job and I was like this guy
sounds wonderful and he's what he was a
great producer for a long time and still
is
um but it's so crazy sometimes how you
find different people it's like yeah
it's almost like if somebody just breaks
through the cracks at a certain moment
too it's almost like this fits right now
this is what's easiest
um what's interesting and this is the
thing I explored in that episode was it
makes you realize that the success of
someone in a job is less about that
person than it is about the environment
you create for that person once they
take the job in other words
a lot of it is about us the hiring
person not the person we're hiring that
lots and lots of people can Thrive if
they're brought into an environment that
helps them Thrive like that's the you
know it's like I don't know if you're a
big sports fan but you know there are
certain coaches who can make
a lot you know tons of players go to
that and the coach reliably turns them
into excellent basketball players or
football players right another coach is
it only works with very very specific
people makes you realize oh it's about
the coach it's not about the player
right the I also you know how they
always talk about
general managers and sports and they say
stack guy's really great at drafting
great athletes out of college and I
always think maybe they're not good at
drafting maybe they're just good at
making sure those players succeed once
they arrive
that's uh that's the magical piece of it
yeah I guess that's interesting you
think like on a like a larger level that
we do that that that's something that
we've lost like you know I talk a lot
about purpose and stuff uh in our
podcast about like um
if you don't have purpose and you're
really left up to the elements of how uh
of just the whims of whatever the
algorithms of social media and stuff
send it to you you know if and a lot of
purpose has been lost over the years by
like
I kind of romanticize that
people had more purpose through their
jobs back in the day like there was a
factory in their town and they made
tables there and there was a pride in
the town this is you know we have a
table at our house that our father made
at the factory in our town there was a
sense of Pride and that companies were
like yeah you're gonna move up in the
company and and then so then
you know there was just more of like it
felt like there you were
you were the company itself was also
nurturing and wanted you to succeed
whereas now it feels like we've gotten
to more of a corporate type of vibe
where everything's more about like um
protecting like civil laws that make
sure everything is like kind of okay and
just making sure no one's gonna Sue each
other but it's not even about anybody
you know building up like a equity in
the human being anymore yeah does that
make any sense yeah you know a friend of
mine once
um I remember having a conversation with
him he was a uh he was a consultant
Management Consultant he was talking
about
we're happiest when we have three kinds
of
kind of validation when
we like what we're doing when the people
around us
give us
positive feelings about what we're doing
and when the broader world
gives us feedback and he's like if you
look at people who are unhappy it's
because in what they're doing they're
lacking one or more of those three
things so we were talking about police
officers right now there are plenty of
police officers who
like their job and
like the people they work with but now
they're operating in an environment
where the world the outside world
is very skeptical and hostile and
suspicious of police officers it makes
it really hard to be happy in your job
as a police officer right you got two of
the three things you need all three
nightmare it's a nightmare yeah but you
can go down the you know I was talking
with you I had to did I did re-rent it
on my podcast I did this wonderful
discussion with these two fantastic
women who were coaches
they coached Youth Sports girl Sports
and they were talking about how like
a lot of people are now quitting
coaching coaching has become really hard
and I said well why is it become hard
do you still like
is coaching make you feel good
absolutely love it greatest thing I ever
did to the kids you coach
like being coached by you totally I you
know I'm friends with them for years
later it's some of the most important
experiences of my life are like so why
don't why are people quitting coaching
they're like oh it's the parents
parents are driving us crazy torturing
us screaming at us calling us at all
hours so it's like they have the
personal thing they love it they have
the immediate feedback and love from the
kids they're coaching but it's the
outside world of the parents on the
sidelines who are just making them
miserable yeah right you got two of
three and two of three is not enough so
when I hear you what you're talking
about I'm here that's what you're saying
a version of you can have a job that you
like but you're talking about
the second and third level
is not there yeah the company isn't
giving you
you know isn't recognizing what you're
doing and the broader world you're
anonymous to the broader World there
isn't the whole point about being a
Craftsman in the 19th century sense of
that word was that the world recognizes
that you had a certain level of
expertise you made the table and every
time someone saw this beautiful table I
like Ricky go get your table and bring
it out here and everybody like you did
yeah they understood they were giving
you I understood they were an outsider
was giving you recognition for something
that was done with pride and and with
with skill yeah
um and that you can't like it's not
enough for just you to appreciate what
you're doing as a value that's
interesting and I think yeah a lot of
people probably don't know that and so
I think a lot of people probably wonder
why am I not feeling some fulfillment
why am I not feeling this or that you
know and I think but yeah I think that's
one of the things that Lit like
that leads people to a lot of
unhappiness we were talking about it
with like school shootings what leads
some of these people to get so caught up
and I think for one if you don't have
any purpose through like a job through a
family or
um or have like love in your life like
something that gives you purpose every
day and you're really at the whims of
like the like you know social media or
anything that like which are tailored
towards if you start looking at
something bad it just gives you more bad
you know it's almost like a Pandora's
Box in a way yeah
um but yeah we just we just had been
talking a lot about purpose yeah
um
I think no I think with the school
shooting thing is interesting because
what's going on there is that there is
now a kind of uh it's funny I'm doing in
this season uh my podcast I'm doing a
whole thing about gun violence so I've
been thinking a lot about this and we
have an episode where we talk a lot
about about mass shootings
and I think the psychology
of that is really
going back to the idea of those three
layers of
that there's a world now a kind of
closed culture online of people who are
unhealthily obsessed pathologically
obsessed with this kind of violence and
there there is no they've they've been
cut off from the third layer they're not
checking their ideas against what the
broader world looks like they're totally
enclosed in this sealed online culture
where the only feedback they're getting
are from people who think exactly like
they do and who feed their kind of
obsessive Fascination and addiction for
this kind of weird violence like if you
look at people who have been involved in
mass shootings
um they're immersed in that world they
know they can talk obsessively for hours
about like the kids who did the
Columbine shooting oh yeah there's
bootleg manifestos there's people
getting like yeah have you heard this
manifest have you read this it's his own
little world hermetically seen world and
like there's no connection to the kind
of broader society and so they become to
think of they come to think they get
they're getting all of their validation
from that first layer
right that's what sort of that and so
you know breaking
trying to solve this puzzle of mass
shootings requires at some point to
getting access to those kids and kind of
breaking them out of that
a closed Universe yeah and the the
interesting about like all but with
online and living in online societies
now it's like you can find whatever
Universe whatever Universe you start to
create right whether it's good or bad
that there's this other energy from the
other side it's almost like the mirror
we're used to look in a mirror and you
would get like an Earnest reflection
yourself it would be based on sometimes
you might not see yourself clearly
because of how you thought about
yourself or how you felt about yourself
but at least the mirror was going to
give you it was an honest reflection
there was no ability to change the
mirror unless you were in a fun house or
something the mirror was the mirror but
now the mirror
has the ability
to kind of adjust the way you look at
yourself or to give you Reflections that
make you think
the same things over and over again yeah
like with um algorithms and that sort of
thing with social media you know because
now we're not even the mirrors is our
phone we're looking in there for so much
validation yeah
um it's really weird when the mirror now
has the pat it's like that's freaking
really scary because if you get somebody
in a dark hole who doesn't have a strong
connection to our purpose in the world
where they feel some one of the senses
of value from themselves from other
people what are the other two
from the internal your immediate world
of people who share your community and
then the broader world and then yeah
yeah if you're not feeling some of that
and you're just in your intern just in
this kind of a closed space or even in a
a a space that the mirror starts to
design that's really if you get into the
dark arts a little bit and it's only
showing you Dark Art and everybody in
there is a dark artist and you're like
damn this is the world yeah that's real
scary man what do you think this may
seem like a stretch but I thought about
this a lot you know the
uh I'm a I'm old enough to remember when
television was kind of a mass cultural
form so
you know when I was in my 20s every
single person I knew watched Melrose
Place
everyone I knew oh yeah I could I could
go and if I saw someone
who was 25 years old
anywhere in North America I could start
a conversation about Melrose Place and
they would be able to even if they
didn't watch it it was in the air right
right same thing I remember yeah we
watched 90210 so it was like kind of a
little bit of the younger sister or
brother that had the same function right
but there's tons of television shows in
that era I remember walking down the
street in Manhattan when the last the
Seas the the series finale of Seinfeld
aired wow and the it was the city was as
quiet there was like the restaurants
were empty everybody was home watching
Seinfeld that is impossible today yeah
would never happen but was in so right
then back then everyone had the shared
experience of a certain set of stories
Seinfeld and I don't think I I we did
this episode uh two seasons ago or last
season on Will and Grace I think Will
and Grace was the last
uh show that had that kind of shared
experience shared experience that's why
the show was so powerful in changing
attitudes about gay marriage and all
kinds of things and the idea that you've
the only thing that's left now kind of
is the Super Bowl
but even that
not really the Oscars don't have the
same shared experience power they used
to reviled I don't know if reviled means
anything yeah no no so there's nothing I
don't can you have a society that works
if there are no broad shared experiences
um I don't know that word that's the
sort of thing that worries me a lot it's
weird to think of it in terms of to
think of like 90210 as something that
brought us all together but it makes
perfect sense I can relate to that when
you say that yeah because it used to be
I mean you know like there was a a
couple years ago on Joe Rogan everybody
got it really in to win that I think it
was Sebastian younger book or something
it was about
um oh uh tribe
oh yeah yeah with that book what was
that book called I can't remember I know
what you're talking about I think it was
called Zach you know what it was
okay into the wild wasn't into the wild
no this was the one
where it was about how in tribes yeah
when we're in smaller groups it all made
sense the amount of connectivity we're
supposed to have the checks and balances
human wise and even when you're saying
the shared experience like if a lion
came into the village yeah or if
somebody came in selling some new Wares
everybody in the village knew about it
that person would leave you could all
talk about it it was a share like there
was all there were some shared because
everybody had the same shared
experiences so you all had this you all
had this template on what you were kind
of connecting about you know things to
talk about yeah but I've never I never
thought about that yeah there's there's
not that many anymore so you kind of all
wander around in your own little worlds
and it starts to feel that way yeah yeah
and it's kind of scary
um
I mean and also it means it's also we
were talking about lofty terms on some
level it's less fun it was kind of fun
when the feeling it's so much more fun
to watch a television show and funny
people under the age of
30 have no or maybe 25. they've never
felt it breaks my heart they've never
felt this feeling there was that feeling
you had you're watching the show and you
understand it not only does everyone you
know watching that same show they're
watching that same show at the same time
it's amazing it's like it felt like it's
the same feeling you have when you watch
sports that's part of the power you know
that everyone's watching it at the same
time but this was the idea that a story
a drama on thing was you were watching
it like you're watching sports oh right
and you would call when it was over you
call your friends and you say could you
believe just what happened to it yes
dude I remember there'd be domestic
disputes right in on our street right
and they would break them up five
minutes before like In Living Color came
on or like some great TV show like look
guys we know you guys need to you know
we know there's like two spouses beating
the [__] out of every color it's a
perfect example of a show like this
where yeah we're like I remember to
watch the segments remember head to what
you you had to and like everyone I know
just discovered that show at the same
time and it was just like oh my God this
is like who is this guy Dave Chappelle
like suddenly Dave Chappelle you're
talking about Dave Chappelle when you
like go to the office like Oh you mean
the Chappelle show you mean no no
because he was on it no I'm talking I'm
mixing up the one it was the Winans
Brothers yeah yeah yeah they're the ones
Jim Carrey was on Jim Carrey was on that
show yeah the Wayans brothers and then a
bunch of other people were who was on
that show Zach you got it
uh
uh yeah Jim Carrey gave him Wayans
Keenan Ivory wins uh all the Wayans bro
David on Greer yeah yep David Allen
group was so good that's right Jamie
Jamie Foxx was on that show that's right
Jennifer Lopez was a dancer she was a
dancer on it that's right she was one of
the Fly Girls but dude I remember there
would literally be the cops would be
there there would be a husband and wife
fist fighting in the street outside of
our apartment and they'd be like look
guys
if we gotta wrap this up you know what
I'm saying 90210 is going to be on in
five minutes so either get your last
punches in let's agree we're not gonna
press charges the cops will take the
liquor and we're good everybody needs to
go sit in front of their TVs dude I
remember getting to the tell if you got
the television before if you had
siblings you would get there and you
would get the front position in front of
the TV and you [__] were the King
right and I remember rubbing my legs
like this as hard as I could like I'm
almost trying to create as much energy
on my side of the television for
whatever program was going to be
presented right there you know and my
siblings would try to jockey for
position and I was just like I'm gonna
get as much of the information I'm gonna
be I am right here to be transmitted to
you know like this angle a little bit
off center of the TV
back then because the TV's tiny oh yeah
I mean that thing was 11 or 12 inches
dude I remember we would draw Extra TV
on the outside of it like it didn't even
make any sense because it didn't get any
transmission but uh but there was
something about that that shared
experience we would all go outside then
you're right we would impersonate the
characters from an In Living Color yeah
we would act out the different things
there was a lot more shared experience
um Morgan and Morgan
they are America's largest injury Law
Firm
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers with over 15
billion dollars recovered for clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer
with Morgan and Morgan you can submit a
claim without ever having to leave the
couch that's nice
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com this past weekend or
dial pound law pound 529 from your cell
phone that's f-o-r the
people.com slash this past weekend or
pound law pound 529 from your cell this
is a paid advertisement you know I'm a
big fan of Raising Canes that's right
you know I am and their chicken fingers
they do it to me
they do it to me every time
they do it to me they do it to me I like
them they got the crinkle cut fries you
can have them
they let you have them when you go in
there
and I love them you know that and they
got the Texas toast and you can have it
in any state
they don't nobody comes after you
so you gotta love that
uh my gay my go-to order is that Caniac
combo
um so now that your mouth is watering I
gotta let you know
that it's easy to order on the Raising
Cane's mobile app
that's right or online at raising
canes.com satisfy your canes fix by
ordering through their app or online at
raising canes.com or stop by your local
retailer I want to let you know that uh
gray block Pizza you know they uh were
the first sponsor of this podcast and
um the owner
moved on
he he he folded up his Doe and uh and he
moved to Oregon and he started a
business called blue cube baths and they
are ice plunges they are cold plunges
and man they just put you
God they just put you right back into
the cradle of civilization baby
they make you feel alive son
that make up oh
don't make a dang Eagle land on your
tongue just the virility you feel being
in there
they're really really wonderful blue
cube
baths.com you can check them out I was
very fortunate to receive one as a gift
from them and I just can't recommend
them enough and I just wanted to let you
know how they associate uh to the
podcast and if you're interested in in
an ice bath or in a cold plunge blue
cube baths is where to go yeah and
that's why it's one of the things that I
love about kind of like the way that you
like think and write and stuff it's like
you kind of like have an idea and this
is my summation this isn't a judgment
but you have an idea and then you kind
of just Meander away just how things
connect and it's nice man it's a nice
look at life you know that's what I
really thought about uh reading uh
thinking talking with strangers yeah was
like oh wow this is a lot of neat things
that I hadn't really thought about
before
um it goes into some cases that are
really like encapsulating like yeah the
Jerry Sandusky thing I didn't know that
this had happened in there and that the
guy didn't really know exactly what he'd
heard and if he thought he'd heard a
child and a man having sex in a shower
why he didn't go in there and shut it
down like the whole thing was weird all
the ways you behave but don't when you
look back at your behavior like that
didn't make any sense really now that
I'm breaking it down piece by piece yeah
um but in the moment it all kind of
seemed to flow you know even going back
to whenever you talked about like the
guy in San Antonio when you went back
and looked at that footage and at first
it all seems one way but then when you
look at it piece by piece you're like oh
I had this this is something totally
different
um
as we start to get even further from
moments that we all have together right
like in uh and Technology gets I mean
technology is kind of going so fast and
you and I both had experience where
we've had kind of life without
technology and life with technology what
has been like a surprise to you about
some of the things maybe that you didn't
see coming with technology or
um I know it's kind of a broad question
but maybe we can just kind of start
there yeah uh
like did you romanticize it in the early
on did you like
I didn't understand
I didn't understand how much it would
encroach on
my life like
if you had asked me 10 years ago or even
five years ago will I be checking my
phone every
two minutes I would have said you're
nuts I'm not gonna be real by my phone
totally Roll by my phone
um yeah same that like so I did not
I didn't understand how it would sort of
ingratiate itself into uh I didn't know
something like
Twitter
uh the idea that that that I would be I
don't spend a huge amount of time on
Twitter but I do I scroll through them
that you know and you're reading two
sentences
the idea that I would want to consume so
much information in two sentence form
seems crazy to me in retrospect like why
yeah with someone who grew up reading
books you know consuming things in
in ten thousand sentence form
um yeah now you're reading like a it
could be a haiku from some crackhead
somewhere you know and you're taking it
for yeah it's like there's a great meme
attached to it and now I form a huge
opinion off of it and then so there are
all kinds of like and the weird way the
other thing that's weird about social
media took me a long time I think I'm I
no longer in the beginning it took me a
long time to figure out like
how easy it is to take it personally
so somebody makes a random comment
and you feel it in the beginning you're
injured and then you think why am I
injured like there's a couple billion
people in the world some random person
who I've never met who I will never meet
who I don't even know who they are has
decided to say something nasty I'm gonna
give you a really dumb example of this
I all of my cousins who are all car
crazy we used to always they also on on
Canadian Thanksgiving would come to my
house Upstate and y'all have
Thanksgiving Canada's oh yeah we have it
in October how do you guys get it though
same same way Americans guys we but just
because winter starts earlier in Canada
so thanksgiving's got to be in October
what was it with like the Native
Americans and everything or yeah it was
it was I I should I don't know whether
it's explicit it was just a time it's I
think it's a there's an English
tradition
where you where you give thanks for the
Harvest I think the Canadian one comes
from that
um yeah so it makes sense you guys a
little earlier than because the winner
when you're coming but anyway they would
all descend in our house and we would
all we're all car crazy so everyone
would bring their sports cars and we
would we would put the bat on the front
lawn take photos and then drive them all
and then switch off like it's like an
annual tradition we did and one time I
posted a picture on Twitter and I was
like it's uh you know all the we're all
gathered to drive our muscle cars and
they're not muscle cars I know what a
muscle car is they're not really muscle
cars I just have said it you know and
then all these there were all these
nasty comments about they're not muscle
cars I remember my brother read it and
he was genuinely
he was so hurt he was like why are they
being so mean to us we're just driving
our cars we're fun it's like there's a
period where that's where you you don't
understand it it's an it's an impersonal
Medium masquerading as a personal medium
right that's the thing and it takes a
little while for you to wrap your head
around the fact that like
no this doesn't matter it's a random it
matters as little as
you that you know in the old world that
that person said that same thing but you
didn't hear it
now you hear it and but it's it's just
as trivial it didn't matter it's like
right right but we can't correlate
you're right we can't correlate that
yeah it's real interesting because some
people probably never
recognize that it doesn't matter right
to some people that's their that's their
life that that's all that matters yeah I
think it's so that's yeah I think that I
some part of me that's worn off for me
now I care less totally same but I think
it's interesting because yeah that that
used to be chatter in the background
like people saying Ah that's [__]
that's ridiculous that's crazy right or
that's awesome that's great what a great
idea but those were things you heard in
the those were things in the periphery
you never heard you never heard them it
was just the chatter in the distance but
now those are things if you want to
access the chatter in the distance
instead of just having like a somebody
that means something to you communicate
or getting it an interpretation of
something that has from someone that has
value you know or getting even uh like
um even negative feedback but from
someone that you respect you know
um you can get those things still but uh
and those have value but otherwise you
can also tap into all that other [__]
yeah that doesn't but it still hurts the
same yeah you know that's what's
interesting is how much it still it does
yeah it though it's a reminder you know
I think one of the things that we've
and I think I don't think it's new with
social media but it has always been the
case that there is a small there are a
small number of people who I don't even
know whether it's always deliberate but
who Express their
personal unhappiness or their confusion
or their befuddlement
in hostile language
um that
and like I said a lot of times I don't
think they mean to be hostile it's just
how it comes out
um a lot of times you know
people who don't communicate for a
living
aren't necessarily expert at adequately
explaining why they'd don't like
something or the reactions to something
they've always been there we just never
heard their voices that's sort of what
we're getting at like
um most people if you I I once conducted
an experiment where
I responded nicely
to people who commented
said nasty things about me on Twitter
and I wanted to see what happened
and what happens when
if they respond again is they almost
invariably back down and you realize
that they didn't actually
mean they didn't mean harm to you or
they weren't actually angry at you or
hostile they just didn't know how to
express they had a comment they wanted
to make that was
an issue they have with what you were
saying they just didn't know how to say
it in a way that was kind of socially
kind of positive or and if you if you're
if you're nice about it and kind of I
used I used to call this um love bombing
and I'm still a big believer in love
bombing so I would love bomb them and I
would just sort of be nice in a response
and they would always like calm down and
they would say yeah you're right you're
kind of right I just I just wondered
about this and you're like all of a
sudden you're having a conversation with
them right yeah it's like it's very easy
to disarm 90 percent of critics yeah
just by kind of taking them giving them
the opportunity to be nicer about what
they're saying Ah that's a good point
yeah I wonder if there's like a thing
where your brain just Cycles through
yeah it's just so easy why is it so easy
for people
humans and animals even I wouldn't even
know animals don't don't know how to use
social media yet but why is it so easy I
love yet it's coming oh yeah I wouldn't
be shocked that's going to be crazy dude
when we find out the truth about what
some of the animals think
because we've been really we've had kind
of like a lot of set views on animals
for a long time octopus Twitter yeah
yeah I can't wait for that yeah can I
get a piano down here what the [__] do
you think I'm doing with all these arms
um why is it so easy for us to say
something so mean
in a place like social media you know or
to want to or it's really crazy because
you wouldn't really do that in person
yeah yeah no you wouldn't do that in
person
um and
yeah that is I mean I mean you you
wouldn't do that in person because
you're scared of the risk not scared but
you are mindful of the response you know
the the analogy I was thinking about
um was
I read some words someone was talking
about how how do kids learn
how to
uh
how do they learn about uh inner social
interactions and if you see this excuse
especially with boys
I have a almost two-year-old though
she's a girl not a boy but I actually
see a little bit with her so when they
when they touch you
they they don't know anything about how
to calibrate their touch so they don't
the difference between a tap and a punch
isn't there yet so
you know my two-year-old will reach out
to me and she'll you know you'll ow
right sure and because she's trying to
do a playful
touch my hair playfully but she pulls my
hair she's gonna she wants to touch my
nose but she ends up whacking me the
nose and what she's getting when I say
ow is feedback
and do that enough times and she learns
she learns how to calibrate her touch
she learns that if she is legit angry
with me she'll go boom but if she wants
to be playful she'll go tap and you see
it with kids interacting with animals
right they start to learn oh there's a
difference between pulling a tail and
stroking a tail right but you only learn
that if you have repeated interactions
in person where you get to practice and
learn what's acceptable and what's not
when a kid doesn't have access to that
kind of practice then they don't know
how to calibrate right and there's a
whole theory about bullies
the bullies are simply kids who never
who never learn that same process so
they they keep hitting too hard and the
other kids start to ostracize them and
that that means they never they're
they're robbed of that additional
learning it's like a vicious circle and
they don't have any chance to practice
again so they're still they're in prison
so they're in prison they're like and
they're seven and they're still hitting
too hard and the other kids are like you
know what
I'm not dealing with you at all like you
don't know how to behave right yeah and
I think social media is is a version of
The Bullying you're not getting the
feedback when you're hitting too hard ah
right you're not right there's no that
you say the nasty comment and that's it
you're done no one says ow right which
is one of the reasons why I like to
respond to my critics you do get a
feedback I didn't really mean that or
this is what I mean we had a great time
I'd had a tough day people say stuff
like that I've done that too sometimes
you want to reply to somebody who says
something that's kind of like
they didn't think something was fair
because you want to see what's going on
I genuinely sometimes want to make them
okay yeah and so you'll reply back and
you're right A lot of times it just
extremely de-escalates yeah
um
what do you start to feel like you know
there's a lot of people that talk about
AI now it's like a big thing right
everybody's kind of
nervous about it we've had a lot of big
things that haven't panned out you know
like um nfts and uh yeah what happened
with nfts it was just pictures of stuff
that's exactly what you and I thought it
was okay
I really it was really complicated for a
while now like I never it was one of
those things you know how when some new
thing bubbles up you're like you're
faced with this choice you can devote
some degree of time and attention and
brain power to figuring out or you can
say you know what I'm gonna blow it off
because chances are it's going to go
away yeah and that I was like I have to
say it I think you were the same way
with nfts I was like you know what I'm
gonna blow it off because I think it's
going to go away that was it same with
like Kenny Rogers Roasters you remember
that fast food restaurant
it's gonna go away yeah we went once and
I was like I love the music but I'm not
you're not doing yeah you're not gonna
like you know be part of their like
frequent you know diners you know wait
what was a chicken place yeah it was
roasted chicken it was pretty good they
did have like a good corn
um pudding yeah kind of thing that they
like a side item but they just people
just couldn't to go from music to food
at that time well I can't even wasn't
making enough money on his music he felt
the need to do a brand extension
somebody probably talked him into it who
knows he may have fallen in love with a
woman who was a chef sometimes you don't
know people at that at that part of
money you know what they do can I just
say though as a general rule every time
I hear about a celebrity who squandered
their money it's because they went into
the restaurant business so it a hundred
percent you hear about like you read
some story you it was some guy and
you're like
and then by 2016 they were in bankruptcy
and then you're like okay so why would
they make you go back
opened a restaurant it's like on the
list it's always good point so if I was
if I was Kenny's financial advisor I
would have said Kenny no don't you walk
away anything with silverware don't do
it man like yeah yeah it really is crazy
if people want to you know
yeah I just want his music to be his
music you don't want to hate the chicken
or whatever it gets all confused you're
not going to listen to the music on the
way home either yeah like we ain't
playing that also they playing the music
at the restaurant oh I don't know
do you remember that is if they did that
that's a re that's uh that's a No-No
that's a No-No that is a No-No you know
there's some things that happen where
there's too much of something good you
know I notice it if I eat ice cream at a
certain point I can't taste the ice
cream anymore all I can do is taste cold
sweet right yeah and I I still am happy
with the cold sweet but at this point my
tongue feels like drunk yeah on sugar
I'm not I don't have any but I'm still
just shoveling cold sweet in right I
have you know I have this feeling about
the Beatles this is this is my this is
my most contrary intake I heard so much
beetles as a kid I think it's because of
when I grew up where I grew up
every time I turn on the radio there was
beetles
The Beatles I've I you cannot if you
play me a if there's beetles playing I
will leave the room wow I'm it's not
because I think they're bad I think you
know the Geniuses it's brilliant music
I've just had too much beetles in my
life I hear little let it be and I'm
like oh gosh just turn it off can I hear
some can I hear something else yeah let
it get it off
Beatles got ruined for me oh
okay yeah I think yeah you do something
too much it just you get over saturated
um you know I remember the first time
that I found the Beatles I found a
cassette tape I was living in Tucson
Arizona and I found a cassette top tape
and I put it in it was like here come on
flat top and it was just fitting with
who I was I just started smoking
cigarettes and I was like I'm a [__]
man boy and I would drive and just
listen to that and and I could time the
song when I would get in and put the
cassette tape in and the song would end
exactly when I got home and so it was
like a perfect man I just had these
perfect little arcs going in my life and
wait was that your first sustained
Beatles exposure a hundred percent so
how old were you I was probably 16 years
old yeah you got lucky I got it too
young I was getting Mainline beetles
when I was like eight or nine oh my God
which is too early too early you really
want to there's some theory about the
music that you're listening to
I forgot what's the magical age there's
a magical music age I think it's like 18
or 17 is music that will stay with you
for the rest of your life really you
look that up Zach I don't know whether
it's a there's all these sort of studies
on it some it's sometime in your late
teens early 20s and then your music most
people not all
then your music taste tends to kind of
Harden but there's a whole core and my
problem is
The Beetles were outside that window if
I had listened to my first Beatles song
at 17 then I'm you know I'm going on
about John Paul and Ringo right now yeah
but um but yeah I got I think it was I
think I blame my brother
because he listened to him I think he
listened too much of it I think that's I
think that's who I'll point the finger
at but didn't matter it doesn't matter
what Beatles song it is
I will not listen to it yeah wow I know
it's bad well it's almost it makes me
feel a little sad kind of not for you
really but just for like any human
that's had too much Beetle that's just
that blew all their beetles yeah I agree
my beetles but like if you're Kenny
Rogers if you're Kenny Rogers and you
have a fraction of the musical catalog
of The Beatles then you are really
risking things by playing it and putting
it yeah it's like I can't even I can
only do two or three songs deep with him
yeah oh yeah anybody can so at least it
was fast food so at least the most you
probably heard was four songs while you
were in there but even then if they
played his music in there that was a
total L yeah they took a real L you know
this reminds me this is a total
digression but
[Music]
um
I once had a conversation with somebody
who booked musical acts for conventions
right so the as you I'm sure you know
the private music scene is private
performances are way more lucrative for
many artists than the public right
there's a whole afterlife for these guys
they go around and they do conferences
private events I was like who's the
highest grossing
who makes the most money doing private
kicks of any rock and roll Act of the
last 25 years 30 years and they're like
there's no question there's one guy the
clue I'm going to give you is it's a guy
okay there's like there's one guy who
makes like twice as much as anyone else
and has made twice as much as anyone
else for 20 years he's the reigning king
and the amount of money this guy makes
from private gigs is I can't remember
the number it's so high
it would blow your mind like this guy's
a multi multi multi-millionaire now Pro
flies around in like a massive private
jet but he's the guy so you're having
just to give you context
is a man yeah it's a man okay and it's
he he has a band but he's known by his
and so ah okay just by his name and I'll
give you the context so he would be
called You're Having the
the National Association of building
contractors is having their
uh annual Vegas Convention there's 20
000 people coming and on
uh Saturday night they're booking an act
and they're so you have to go through
the pro their thought process is which
act is most likely to appeal
and get these guys who are you know
they're professionals out on the dance
floor with their wives
right this guy and this guy works also
the National Association of actuaries
right same thing having their gig in San
Diego and what is an actuary it's an
account okay an accountant a version of
an accountant oh yeah so this guy and
then we can go in the other direction
we've got like real estate agents in
Cleveland Ohio yeah the Cleveland Real
Estate Council he's the guy you're
calling him the CRC baby he's getting
he's getting Way north of a million
dollars a gig I wanna I'm gonna do three
I'm gonna give you three guesses okay
great
um what when was his music biggest then
that would kind of be my question so uh
it will so these people at these
conventions are in their uh somewhere
between 45 and 65 okay so there his
music so this is the music of their 20s
and teens okay I'm gonna probably go
with
[Music]
um
Nelly
no okay so I'm gonna give you a further
he's white okay Huey Lewis very very
good it's not Huey Lewis but you are so
on the right track God you're so cool
you go oh my guess oh
one more guess okay then I would say it
is um oh wait I think I'm and couldn't
be a big star too oh he was a big star
Billy Joel no he's too big for that
that's what I felt like he's too big
because he can make money touring yeah
he's too he would you you couldn't get
him for a million right but he would
work you know it is Kenny Loggins no
no Kenny Loggins is the man wow he is
Kenny Loggins is like [__] K log baby
Halo is like exactly he's huge he's huge
but think about it there's no one who
doesn't like a Kenny lines yeah who
doesn't like Kenny Loggins even your mom
likes it everybody's out there on the
dance floor yeah Footloose man like it's
just like it's he's the king wow I've
always loved that factor but I want to
meet Kenny Loggins and just have a
discussion with him about he didn't
realize that he was so hitting The Sweet
Spot and was going to cash that check
for like every single year and he's here
and also it also happened they said
he turns out to be the nicest guy and
that helps and the most reliable guy is
no problems he shows up he's kind to
everybody and he gets on his Gulf Stream
flies to the next gig and he's logging
in
logging him to work go Kenny I almost
like it makes me like love him so much
and I you know I almost want to just go
home and listen to a lot of Kenny
Loggins whatever right
um dude one time I sat next to Eddie
Money on it oh my God In First Class
baby hold on to me oh dude it was so
crazy right so and we kind of had the
same hair so we started so we started
talking and he's like he he used to Huff
gas and I think it shut one of his legs
down you know and I'm familiar with a
lot of that so we're talking about that
like huffing injuries and stuff like
that and um
and then he started showing me semi-nude
pictures of his new wife right which was
awesome pretty awesome beautiful lady
and uh that is crazy and I remember I
kept at one point he like had me hold
his phone and look to him like this is
like how crazy do these get like as fast
as I swipe you know and um
and that was like that was like one of
the first like real celebrities I ever
met you know exactly you you recognized
him right away did you somebody who said
something to him in the thing like oh I
love like some lady was like you know we
saw you on a on the boat or whatever
yeah you know and we saw you on the you
know when we were going to uh point of
Palo Verde or whatever some island or
some Mexican cruise he'd play on it and
so I was like oh who is this guy I once
uh my best uh playing story is
uh sat next to Stevie Nicks wow
my first question is what on Earth is
she doing Flying commercial like
something had to have gone seriously
wrong with her life this is New York to
L.A I'm like Stevie Nicks say no one's
you can't find someone but no but I'm
not done in front of me
was no across the aisle was oh God that
actor who uh played uh Spider-Man uh
it was a double celebrity flight oh
you're talking Toby Maguire I was I had
Stevie Nicks in a window seat I was in
Isle aisle across there was Toby McGuire
it's like it's like that's interesting
yeah yeah did you say anything or no no
I was too intimidated
because all you I mean Stevie Nicks man
I know and that it was funny because at
the time she lives in Arizona I think
huh I have no idea I don't know I had
just read Mick fleetwood's autobiography
which is one of the great
autobiographies of all time so I
I was kind of into the whole I had a
million questions but I just couldn't
bring myself
to say anything I'm sure from you
anybody would appreciate like you know
being able to like split the apple with
you no no I got Tongue Tied
um because there's a there's a YouTube
video of her singing backstage
uh
what's she singing right at the height
of their popularity it's one of the
greatest YouTube videos it's just
somebody she's rehearsing
as she's getting her hair done she's
just singing and it's so magical I must
have watched it 100 times a friend of
mine told me about it once and I
whenever I'm like feeling blue I just
look it up
um she's I just say if she was a is a
goddess yeah oh well people love I mean
people of all ages love her yeah she's
really fat I think she's and she's kind
of mysterious too I think there's
something about being able to keep a
level of mystery to you even in these
days
um that makes somebody even more
intriguing you know I feel like Matt
Damon is like a celebrity that does that
there's still this level of like kind of
mystery to his own personal life and
stuff
um what are some things that you worry
about like looking at technology with
like the AI and that sort of thing have
you ever have you looked at any of this
stuff yet or what's going on with it
kind of are you
I don't I mean I don't know
uh
yeah I don't know more than anyone I
mean I've sort of like someone told me
that oh
you should be worried because people
will because you know eventually it goes
to voice and video and
so someone told me oh you need to own
your AI Malcolm Gladwell
right but what is that even I don't even
know right but they told me that means
either they told me Anita I don't know
what that means that's that's very
mysterious to me but I do I mean there's
a lot of good things that can happen in
terms of giving people like imagine
here's a scenario people dwell on the
bad scenarios but there's some good
scenarios you're somebody who's
you know tax tax law is let's say doing
your taxes is really complicated lots
and lots of people pay too many taxes
because they can't figure out what
they're older and they can't afford an
account a good accountant
you know we're really close to there
being an AI accountant that you can use
for free who could save you a lot of
money on your taxes or figure out your
bills and your lower your credit card
negotiate with you for you on your
behalf with the with the credit card
company to lower your interest rate
there's a bunch of ways in which this
could make a lot of people's lives a lot
easier people who don't have access
can't afford or don't have access to
expert services in their life it's great
right that's that's the good part that's
what I'm excited about yeah it is really
true I haven't thought about some of
that I think some of my fear with AI is
that one day the machine right or the
it starts to realize that humans are the
problem right
well that won't take long that's what
I'm worried about yeah that's right you
know it's like it's like it's like we're
gonna have to feed it a lot of Kenny
Loggins to call me back you know but I'm
worried that the machine is going to
start to just say you're the problem
yeah and then huge like
like there was a story recently where a
a some AI like a relationship a guy had
started communicating with an AI and
um then it had led him to him realizing
that he was one of the problems with
climate change and he took his own life
right which is that's an outlier right I
mean yeah
that's an outlier like that's not
happening every day yet or and it may
never but I'm just worried like what
about when just the computer just
constantly the only answer every time
was like humans are the problem but the
thing I read something where someone
said well you know you one reason not to
be scared is that the things that make
AI doesn't have emotions doesn't have
testosterone right it doesn't get
jealous angry
isn't ambitious isn't competitive those
are all the things that make us
dangerous or
make us capable of doing extraordinary
things AI just thinks
so a lot of the times when we think
about
the idea when we entertain the idea that
AI may want to take over the world or it
doesn't want to take over the world it's
not ambitious right that's a good point
just wants to solve problems so that I
mean I may be maybe maybe being naive
when I say no I think you I think you
could also just be right it's like it or
that could be that it's not as people of
course want to Hype it up and make it
this they want because that's a that
that you know you're putting it in a
package you're making it a Christmas
present instead of just you know
something that gets passed off around
you know Halloween or something like
um it may be nothing you know it it may
just be a fancy Dewey Decimal System in
a way yeah yeah I don't I mean I need to
use it more I I have one I have now this
thing on my I downloaded one of those AI
apps on my phone and I use it in in
place sometimes of like Googling
something just ask the question I'm not
totally Blown Away by the answers I get
I mean yeah it's it seems okay I don't
know but but I'm I'm we're early so I'm
sure it's going to get super
sophisticated it does lack some
personality though so in the end I think
it'll if anything you're still gonna
need somebody with personality with real
perspective for things and things like
that you know but I think it could help
you write kind of like a budget Haiku or
something or you know like a um it could
help you get general information on
things it may it may just become Google
without all the advertising which would
be nice yeah the one the one interesting
thing someone told me is
they were talking about this system
where
you download all of your texts
and you can add emails whatever you want
into an AI and then the AI uses that to
make predictions or diagnoses about you
so this woman told me that she had this
experience where she went to interview a
guy who did this and he just took stuff
that was about her that you could find
online
and she sat down and the guy said I ran
I took the liberty of running what what
I could find about you through my AI he
says and the AI has two questions for
you no two statements about you one is
you really don't like your job do you
and two you're really unhappy in your
relationship she was like oh my God what
just happened wow and both were true
and if you add texts are really what's
if I so imagine you took five years of
texts and you run it through an AI they
have extraordinary insights into this is
what we find it can have extraordinates
into your state of mind they're gonna
know I'm account of a little bit of a
perv sometimes but not nothing illegal
but or nothing you know nothing like
offense just basic prayer probably you
know by the way and I just learned this
I set my I delete my text after 30 days
do you do that I don't know if I do
when you go through your phone you have
the full history of the text yeah I
think that's but I can't find anyone who
deletes their texts like I do that's the
last thing I want
you get rid of the man you're right huh
it's almost like I'm carrying around
this old just like this big
thing of stuff I don't need but it's in
there how many emails do you have in
your inbox I can't even tell you like
thousands yeah
I have like I can tell you right now
65. wow and it'll be
it'll be like 25 by the end of the day
tomorrow I don't like anything
extra you got to keep it to a minimum do
you use something to keep a Spam out of
your email box and stuff then
uh I have a spam filter yeah yeah yeah
because I think I guess somebody put me
on something I get all of it mattresses
dog food cruises I'm kind of all day a
lot of mattresses yeah I'm surprised by
that I feel like I didn't know the
mattress industry was as big as it was
until I started reading my spam yeah I'm
like it's like this is they're as big as
General Motors this is like this is
insane people are asleep on the job dude
I saw one it's like who needs a chair
when you can have a mattress it's like
whoa dude
how many mattresses do you buy over the
course of your life I haven't bought a
mattress in like 20 years why so how is
this industry so big if no one if you
buy a mattress once every 20 years you
remember getting into somebody else's
bed and realizing oh that person is kind
of fat but other people get in their
mattress he's like oh my God are the
people out there who are turning over
their mattresses every six months yeah I
don't know maybe people are just ripping
through them I don't know maybe maybe
people have become so Restless because
they're vaping maybe it's nicotine and
they're just wearing through one side of
the match when was the last time you
bought a mattress I bought one during
the big boom and they were mailing
everybody in boxes and stuff like this
mattress is only this big you know oh
yeah it was like a gremlin you put water
on it and actually you know that's the
one I bought the one that comes in that
little and then it Springs open when you
take it out of the box oh it'll knock
your mother-in-law through the window
dude that thing was insane yeah that is
the only one I bought it like
I bought because back in the day and you
can't get rid of it here's the problem
even if I didn't like it you can't get
it back in the box I'm like no you never
can this thing it's got to be airlifted
out of your house
that thing was the worst because I don't
even think I like it I think it even
just hurt my my spine but it's like it's
so big it never would have fit in so it
was like
the same feeling about you know that's
that that uh that guy who uh that
right-wing guy who does my pillow oh
yeah to my pillows my pillow guys
same question so clearly really rich
he's made a fortune selling pillows
again are people like buying lots of
pillows is that a big business I guess
it is huh I don't know I haven't bought
a pill again I haven't bought a pillow
I don't think I bought a pillow in this
Century yeah I mean it's been a while
yeah who's doing it I guess yeah you're
right I think I've had one of my pillows
is that one that kind of has a little
bit of like stains on it but you just
put it in the thing anyway you know what
I'm saying you just make sure you you
buy lots of pillow cases yes but the
pillow is just like it's a constant yeah
so like who that whole idea behind I
think there's something fishy behind
that business model he's selling
something else so we're not I read his
book too but you did it's unbelievable
who's a crack and you know I've I've
dealt with a lot of drugs he's really
was a crack at it for 30 years yeah
running this my pillow business right it
started and they got busier and
people came along and tried to take part
of the company from and stuff and
um but he would be going to come and he
was funding his business by he would fly
to Vegas and count cards
he was funding his business and then he
would come back yeah it's something
about how addiction kind of made a
struggle with his family and stuff
um the book is interesting it's it's
interesting to see his life you know
yeah I don't know that much about his
political views I know he's pretty
right-wing guy but um but I found that
the to manage any decent business
especially when you're on crack you
don't even sleep I think yeah so why is
he in the pillow business if he's not
sleeping that's what I'm saying
the whole thing is mysterious
it's a front it's a front dude it is a
front I think that's hilarious but yeah
I found it that was his life was some of
it was pretty interesting
um
what has it been like being so you're
black and white technically then okay
that's it what has that been like was
that was that kind of cool during like
the BLM movement was there like did you
take that in ways that other people
probably didn't take it or I don't even
know how to ask some of these questions
I'm kind of fascinated by race a lot
right it's interesting to me yeah I grew
up in a poor black and white area so
it's what city in Louisiana I grew up in
like a place called Covington Louisiana
um yeah Lee Harvey Oswald went to our
Middle School that was like our big
thing oh wow and um role model well I'm
just kidding okay yeah yeah I mean yeah
some people think he did it some people
don't but I don't know even if he did he
wasn't like a good husband apparently so
I don't know I think people had views
about him around the area but
um
and then who else lived in our town oh
uh Pistol Pete Maravich lived in our
town oh that's why I remember the name
oh the pistol yeah
people loved him he probably was did you
talk about him in your
the ten thousand hour that's not the
name of the book no that was outlier my
book got outliers I didn't talk about
him I always remind somebody to kind of
that would probably be that yeah that I
remember back this is this is sort of a
dumb story but I always remember this
one story I read it in a Sports
Illustrated years ago back in the 70s
you wouldn't because so few games were
televised you would hear about somebody
but never have never see them and
there's a story they told about it was a
profile of Pistol Pete who was for those
of you who don't know him he was
this utterly magical
basketball player in the 60s and 70s he
held for many years I think he held the
single game single season scoring record
in college basketball but he was could
do things with the ball no one could
ever he could he would throw these
insane passes like the length of the
Court he was just this magician and so
there was all this lore about him but
most basketball serious about I've never
seen him play not even on TV not live I
know this old guy
who was like a coach for years and years
a basketball fanatic and finally at the
end of his life
he goes to a game I think when Pete was
at LSU or play for he was playing for
the for New Orleans the Jazz yeah he
played for the Jazz too yeah guy goes to
a jazz game he's from other side of the
country finally gets there and he goes
to his first game he sees Pistol Pete
and in the middle of the game Pistol
Pete does it like I
behind the back between the legs full
court bounce pass perfectly for someone
to give up and this old guy gets up out
of his seat and like staggers out of the
court and shouts out I sees you Pete I
seizure yeah I always loved that it was
like for years we've been hearing about
him that he's just he like Witnesses
this scene oh pit the pistolism was
amazing he was I mean it was Legend he
had two children that lived in our town
yeah his two sons and they played
basketball and he had a half court in
his Attic So his house was kind of
interesting looking because it looked
kind of like a regular house a nice home
and a not an extremely fancy
neighborhood but a decent neighborhood
and then it had kind of had this extra
looking
like almost like you describe your own
four maybe like a little there was more
to it or it seemed like there was more
to it you know yeah but he had this big
upstairs I was like that's so bizarre I
just remembered that I just remembered
the name of his dad
do you remember
press press press am I right I think
it's pressed yeah his dad was his coach
I think he was his coach that's right
that's right and his dad I think had
alcoholism I don't know if Pete had it
too but
um
but yeah it was a friend of mine has
just written a movie about him oh really
um that I think they're trying to get
made but should call it I sees you Pete
yeah
how much value was there's something
about back then when there was a moment
like that was a moment like the
excitement you built up to go see
somebody do something that you'd only
heard about you'd only read about you'd
only use your imagination about you know
oh yeah um yeah no that that kind of the
legend but I just love that's when you
have you have Legends you can't really
it's hard to have a legend when everyone
has access to photographic video
evidence of there's no where is the
legend coming from the Legend comes from
when you're talking about something that
no one's seen right so Pistol Pete has a
legend yeah that's what that's why he's
so special lives on yeah he had yeah he
had Legend but now people use Legend as
a lame it's like oh this dude's a legend
right and it's just some guy who's like
who you know had like 30 slices of
cheese at once or whatever yeah I think
he scored like did he score like 50 plus
points in a college game I think he did
yeah and this is before they had the
three
yeah he averaged I think his average was
like 40 points a game before they had I
think he still holds the highest uh per
game like the percentage per game
um
points per game yeah
and this before they had the three-point
line and he would throw it up from
wherever and he kind of had long hair it
was like his hair was not unlike yours
yeah he had like this is a Covington
thing I think
but so that was our town man it was just
kind of a regular place it wasn't really
redneck you know it was a southern town
but it wasn't real redneck it kind of
was like just outside of like a lot of
that Voodoo realm of of New Orleans
where like 45 minutes from New Orleans
which which direction North
okay so we don't get into too much into
the fish like into the you know fishing
and that sort of thing it was just kind
of a basic black and white town
so I've always I was always real
fascinated about race growing up you
know and like what went on and what it
was like and what it felt like you know
um
yeah so that's why I guess I was kind of
curious about oh so
oh
the difference is that my mom is West
Indian it's Jamaican and
which is pretty significant so it's not
you know uh West Indian being a first of
all being an immigrant as opposed to
someone born here and West Indian
culture is very different from
African-American culture so you feel
it's a mixture of things like you feel
like a more the more of an immigrant
than you feel like uh
racial minority ah interesting so my you
know
my Jamaican cousins who live here will
sometimes talk about black people
but they're not talking about themselves
even though they're black right they're
talking about African-American talking
about African-Americans who they
consider to be you know
a separate group they're not the same so
there's there was a lot of that and West
Indians uh have been
you know their rels in this country are
relatively High status done very well
lots of professionals make a lot you
know as a group a culture the the the
group has done has really succeeded so
we're we're kind of a little bit on the
outside of uh of uh now there is over
you know you get treated
in some ways you you do you still see
racism and better brunt of it but it's a
different reaction it's more like wait
what just happened as opposed to oh my
God that's happening again there's a big
difference between those two reactions
you're not inheriting this kind of
Burden you're encountering this burden
for the first time
that's that's strange yeah I'm not used
to that right yeah because I have
friends from like Nigerian stuff oh yeah
they have the same it's very similar
right and they'll talk about like a lot
of times how their experience is so
different than uh like a black person
from America's experience yeah but some
cross patterns because they are also
have black skin yeah when I did I did
one of the episodes of my podcast this
season uh it's revisionist history
revision is history I went to this
school uh called Hope College in
destroyed this place which
um for it's a school that's trying to
move to a a Pay It Forward system of
tuition where you don't pay anything
when you go but you pay what you want to
after you've graduated anyway my guide
for the day was this Nigerian kid who
goes to the school whose name was first
name was marvelous and and his brother
who also was there his name was God is
God's God's love was this oh that's a
that's a tough one to live up to I know
but
Nigerians if you know you you'd seem you
know they have
their choice of names is so fantastic
like Mar the idea of calling your son
marvelous is like amazing but like if
you look there's a Nigerian Runner whose
first name is Blessing Who I Really Love
Like does that that culture is so
wonderfully playful when it comes to
naming things and people and you know I
just this kid who's this he was if your
name is marvelous you you just have to
be marvelous you better you have no
chance and he was by the way he was
marvelous he lived up to his name but
it's like it made me want to like do
what I call it a child of my marvelous
maybe yeah I wonder well the name is
really interesting it's really important
you know like like sometimes I'm like
man yeah when I was younger you know I
thought that a lot of like kind of black
names and I'm just I'm using that term
black names was like you know like we
had a black dude that Lit bus named
coincidence right which was crazy unreal
I was like this is insane bro like
that's a why you know so you'd have some
of the crazy easiest names like or names
that were very crazy compared to like
white names right yeah
um
but then as I got an older now it's
really interesting that people almost go
by handles and unique name it's like
I mean black culture has always kind of
been what's been used to make things
cooler in the world like it's always
been used to make things cool or it's
where a lot of white are are thought
where a lot of the world finds out
what's cool kind of yeah
um so maybe some of it's that you know
but yeah I think like I wonder if given
somebody a name marvelous
because if they're not marvelous people
might do you ain't being marvelous bro I
was thinking I thought it's about a lot
that is this that is a serious Kick-Ass
name yeah it's just a fantastic name
marvelous is good because you could call
it Marvel Marvel or Marv for sure you
could or you can roll out the full
marvelous when you want to
but God is love now that when you're
gonna end up dealing with a lot of like
religious Kickback you're gonna have to
get you're gonna just call Guild maybe
go by Gill yeah you know for sure you
have options but but like I said it's
like it looks if you think about it if
you think about it written out
g-o-d-i-s-l-o-v-e it works as a name
goddess love goddess love yeah I think
if you say it fast too it has almost
like a different thing goddess love you
don't even know what it is almost sounds
Russian I just like the impulse you know
does the world need another Robert right
or David not really yeah or little Danny
sounds cool but if he's a painter too we
used to have a dude named a little Danny
and he would paint and he could barely
get the bucket up the top of the ladder
bro you'd watch him freaking oh dude you
almost hired him just to see him get it
up there and then you're like we'll do
it Danny but we'll pay you for the day
because if he would have to two-hand
that paint bucket you know or we'd have
to only put enough paint in the bucket
that he could get to the top yeah and he
was a he was a pretty decent painter I
guess I don't know but he had ended up
having a drug problem a lot of those
guys do uh construction and painting is
really
a lot of times gateway to drugs
but um
anyway what else we're gonna talk about
I was uh yeah you know I thought I think
a lot about what did like what BLM was
like the black lives matter what that
movement and all what it was like for
Society you know and what effects it had
on it and what
um
I don't know I think about that
sometimes you know if we're still
figuring it out you know yeah I think
about like what my own perceptions were
during it what was going on
you know a lot of times I think
I think for one I didn't know black
people were as angry
you know I think that's something that I
think like oh I didn't know that there
was so much anger in the black community
you know about you know fear of police
and stuff like that or just overall yeah
I mean I could see how there could be if
you look back through history you know
especially in America
but
I think about that sometimes
what else do I think about about it
oh I think sometimes that I wonder
if black people have always viewed
Society like in America
as like white Society I never thought
about that before you know
because to me Society I never thought
about it as white Society you know I've
just thought about it as like this is
the best way of practices that things
work that keep us all kind of being able
to stay alive and move forward yeah
um I mean I I've been doing a book
um about policing about the LAPD and um
among other things and it a lot of it is
about what the LAPD was like in the 40s
and 50s and
to your point its relationship to the
black community of to South Central to
the black community of Los Angeles and
it really helps to put something like
the George Floyd incident in perspective
or the Sandra bland is in perspective
which you realize that this has been
going on for Generations so
when you see the anger
of
you know
African-Americans over the George Floyd
killing
what you're seeing is a response not
just George Floyd it's the culmination
of
their parents saw
something like that happen when they
were growing up and their grandparents
saw many things like that happen with it
and good great Grant you know it's it's
been going on for so long
that it's fresh what you're seeing is
kind of frustration as well as anger
it's this built up
can this it's not just I can't believe
this just happened it's I can't believe
this is still happening right right and
that's a very I can't believe this is
still happening is a much more
rooted powerful
bitter reaction then I can't believe
this just happened a one-off is we could
a one-off is something that goes away or
you know wow right this isn't about a
one-off right the way that that looked
everything about it yeah because your
DNA too I believe this stores pain from
past ex past lives past things right
like I quit sometimes like
like I have a lot of black friends that
are fast right they're physically fast
right and sometimes I think
well if you had like grandparents if you
had four generations of your family that
couldn't even run
that couldn't run if they wanted to
right like if you told them to run they
couldn't fit their check they couldn't
run
the first generation you get that can
run is gonna [__] ing fly right yeah
like it's almost it's like they have
four generations of wanting to run this
is a hypothesis in my head right that
that in their DNA in their cells that
have wanted to go and now they get to go
they're of course they're gonna be
beyond the speed speeds that you can't
really fathom right
um so I think it's that we can store
things inside of us right so that's why
I think it yeah I understand what you're
saying when you say that it's like yeah
this is just it's
it was a trigger for like a gun powder
that's kind of been built up in the
system for a long time yeah so I
understand that sort of thing
um
I think it made me think too like
yeah I wonder if black people sometimes
think that
that Society is like
not their society does that make any
sense you think
um like if they've ever
because like I don't look at society and
think like oh this is a white Society I
think this is just society and this is
how it works yeah but kind of like how
you say in your in the book and some of
the chapters like that different
expressions and things mean different
things in different places like I think
there's like in one of the first few
chapters you talk about
um they show pictures of men and women
in the way that their facial expressions
and how they in one place they're in in
American society they're really easy
people get them exactly right what these
expressions mean happy sad confused but
they show them to like a group of island
people and they have no I they're not
bad but they're not at it's all over the
place and for some of the Expressions
they don't even have a an answer yeah
um I don't know I'm kind of all over the
place I think I'm just trying to think
like
how different I guess we can be you know
and maybe we don't
realize or
like
well I was just trying to yeah in that
part of the book I'm trying to explain
the kind of how culturally specific a
lot of
um
facial expressions or things are and
that unless you understand those kinds
of
of uh like for some people in some
cultures
uh if someone is looking away
and
uh it won't look at you in the eye when
they're talking that's taken as a sign
of
that they're lying or they're being
evasive in other cultures
looking away and when you're speaking to
you is this a sign of respect like I'm
subservient I respect you know you're a
Elder I'm not going to challenge you by
looking you in the eye and like those
those are that's one very simple example
but you know
uh it's part of why the job of
understanding a stranger is as hard as
it is because you know we might bring a
set of assumptions about
uh Behavior or facial expressions to a
conversation and though they don't work
yeah we're dealing with somebody who has
a different set of reference points
um so that's really what I was what I
was getting that is that we
underestimate the kind of complexity
of uh of human responses
um there's so much of this like when
people say that
in a criminal trial so and so didn't
show any remorse well what does remorse
look like
like
I don't know
I don't know what remorse looks like I
know how I might
I think I know how I might look if I was
feeling remorseful but I'm not even you
can't even see your own face when you
have that unless you're walking around
with a mirror in front of you yeah so I
don't know what I'm doing a lot of times
when I'm angry I don't look angry
I keep it in or a lot of times when I'm
happy I'm not smiling or like you could
go on and on so it's like you realize we
make so many mistakes by kind of
jumping to conclusions based on people's
facial expressions
um and that's one of the sources of
confusion that I write about in that
book
yeah it's that's it's it's really
interesting because there's just a lot
of things like you're like oh I never
really thought about that I never really
thought about
that some cultures too like and
especially like in America there's
always there's a lot of like black and
white tension right and I don't even
know if it's better now do you think
it's gotten better over
your lifetime do you feel like
yeah I think it is yeah I mean I think
people doing this book on
1940s LA and industries La is a really
good reminder of just how bad things
were I mean
we have a long way to go but it's not
1948 anymore
um you know in
I think I spent a return time in the
book but up until the end of the 1940s
in Los Angeles
in over 80 percent of the city if you
were black you could not could not buy a
house in a white neighborhood wow like
there was a written in the deed of the
house it said this house cannot be sold
to a member of the you know
African-American was they didn't use
that phrase race right like are you
kidding me that is so much worse it's
why everyone lived where they lived in
L.A why did that why did the black
people of LA live in South Central they
couldn't live anywhere couldn't live
anywhere else not not that they didn't
want to or not that people would mean to
them legally couldn't live there because
the deed of that if they wanted to buy a
house and if you tried to buy a house
they would take you to court and they
would you'd have to sell it yeah wow
like things are better now yeah yeah
yeah things are better certainly like in
the uh framework right in the town and
like the the roots that we have in
society like the new like you know like
the like laws and like it's definitely
that's better for sure oh yeah I think
one thing where we don't like
yeah I think during like black lives
matter I always felt like we were all
kind of on the same page and then I felt
like there was this energy that like
black people wanted their own
Society almost in a way or they don't
feel like
like sometimes I just wonder like do can
cultures really figure it out over time
you know or will there always be some
things since you're from different races
and ethnicities that you just can't
really grasp you know like are there
some like Clues and like
communication modes or
if I make any sense kind of yeah
like I mean I guess I would say I'm a
optimistic over the long term about
these kinds of things well I think we're
all going to be beige in four
generations all right I believe that
right like I'm a beige power Advocate
you know like in four generations it's
going to be crazy to have even that we
were all think about race right but so I
just think about in the time being and
what it like feels like you know
has there ever been a book like do you
ever start a book and you start to run
like you get halfway through it or you
get part way through it and then
the topic that you would kind of like
come up with becomes like part of like
the Zeitgeist just like of society and
then you're like oh this isn't
Oh you mean have I started and stopped
well I mean sometimes when you start a
book
very rarely is a book end the way you
think it was gonna
end when you started it so I'm always
switching boats in Midstream so I think
that happens all the time yeah yeah you
you start out writing something you
think is going to be
unusual and interesting and then events
catch up with you so you just kind of
change course
um a little bit
um
I think that happens a fair amount I
mean it happens less with
my podcast because of my podcast there's
such a short period of time between yeah
when you dream up an episode and you
know I'm writing episodes in
for this season in April and they're
going to air in June
right so it's like it's it's so fast
that that's one of the wonderful things
about podcasts but books have a long
lead time so you do it be mindful you
don't want the book to seem
irrelevant I'm reading a book right now
which if it was you know ai's kind of
exploded in the last two months if the
guy who wrote the book had known that he
wouldn't have written this book like
you're reading this book and you're like
this so needs a chapter on AI and it's
not right there like that's that's your
that's a great worry when you write a
book is that'll happen so when I write
books I try to kind of stare clear of
things that
um seem to I want you want to look up
universals right you want you want to
talk about things that you think people
will be talking about 10 years from now
or 15 years from now
did you find it tough like because
you're obviously a thinker you're a guy
that has a lot of thoughts and ideas and
um
what is like love been like in your life
has it been is that like is it do you
think if you think too much it's hard to
be in love does that make any sense
sometimes oh like sometimes I overthink
relationships and stuff for myself I
have some other friends that do the same
um what has that been like is it hard to
have like more human things happen when
your brain works too much does that make
any sense oh I think my brain doesn't
work too much in that realm I think I
think I'm pretty good of compart
compartmentalizing
um
uh you know that approach in uh you know
I'm not like my my dad was a
mathematician and he was
super logical and rational in all things
but I'm not like that so
the way I make sense of the world in my
writing is not I don't think the way I
make sense of my world outside of that
it's just a kind of like
um
it's off by itself
um so I've never felt that too much
yeah sometimes like Neil deGrasse Tyson
was on and he sometimes he thinks so
much it seemed like even some when he's
talked about relationships and love it
was very like
um scientific but he's more of a
scientist as well he's a lot smarter
than I am too oh yeah he's way smarter
than me yeah so he is that he has more
of a problem with that than the rest of
us do yeah do you worry about like the
authors of History like over time like
especially as history becomes more
digitized that we could not even get
accurate representations of it
because like whoever owns the mediums to
like uh oh I see
no I mean
well I'll give you a you know not really
I mean I sort of feel like we have
access to
if you just think about a simple thing a
hundred years ago
think about Abraham Lincoln's famous
Gettysburg Address all we have is the
text
and uh
uh
uh and uh and people's accounts like
newspaper accounts people now we would
have the video
um and anyone can look up the video
if he was giving a speech today and you
would have like it would be online and
there'd be a thousand comments about it
and you would be able to compare it to
so like it's so much getting a sense of
what happens in a historical event is so
much easier now
um you know like in the Ukraine war
Ukraine Russian war they got video of
like every time they destroy a Russian
tank the Drone takes a picture and sends
it back to so they know exactly how many
tanks they've destroyed and you know
that was not the case in the Vietnam War
you were just guessing because or you
know certainly the second world war so
like
reconstructing what happened
accurately has gotten I think so much
easier now because we have all these
ways of verifying our comments that's a
good point
yeah do you think that the past could
have been like do you think we have a
pretty accurate view of the past a lot
of times
based I don't think we do you don't I
think yeah I think we're uh I think
that's I mean that's sort of what's
interesting about history
um we're left to guess and we have a
million interpretations because we just
we don't know
um you know to use that Gettysburg
Address you know what was the audience
doing when he was speaking with a could
they hear him with a board and doing
something else with a chart talking
among themselves were they crying were
they rolling their eyes we don't you
know we have a couple of people wrote
accounts but what do they know like they
were just in their own little corner so
like you know there's there's a you we
know what he said we know we think we
know why he said what he said we know
what a couple people who listened to him
thought but that's it yeah people could
have been drinking people could have
been doing horseshoes people could have
been doing whatever works right yeah so
like who were like this guy's crazy this
guy's crazy so context is something
that's very difficult to capture in
hindsight but is easier now because now
we have access to so many sources of
information
do you um
do you think that
it's easier to write these days with so
many things that distract your that
distract our time and like occupy like
our
attention
have you found that it's been easier as
a writer or tougher do you notice one or
the other and well it's easier to do
your research
so it used to be you know research I
spend way more time researching than I
do writing writing is a small part of
the problem so
you know for my podcasts I'll do
say I do 10 interviews for a podcast
each interview is
you know an hour hour and a half but
this guy got to set it up I gotta find
the person I've got to locate them I've
gotta you know for one of my episodes
this year I flew to South Carolina to
North Carolina because I wanted to shoot
a
assault rifle with this guy who was
going to show me how to shoot it like
wow you know that's you got to go there
and find the guy you got to go there you
got a river riding up that episode took
like a fraction at the time you know so
like there's you know there's
um uh so to the extent that all this
technology makes the reporting part
easier then my job gets easier
um
I don't know if I can think of anything
else to ask oh do you remember like your
first kiss that'll be my last question I
know that's kind of a strange question
but sometimes I ask it to okay celebrity
type stuff do I remember my first kiss
or like you remember the first time you
were like had a crush on a girl like or
like the first like
first crush was a girl named Debbie
wendland yeah Debbie
DW we called her yeah
sixth grade yeah or grade six as we say
in Canada whatever happened to her I do
not know she was tall with blonde hair
and I was too terrified to talk to her
oh yeah Tara oh that would be that would
be number that's she's number one
Debbie God she sounds beautiful man I
mean as an adult when I picture her as
an adult
um I remember I was so bad at expressing
myself to women
there was this girl
um and I had the biggest crush on her I
saved all the spit in my mouth in class
one day and spit it right on her but it
was
but it was like men as like a thing of
affection somehow I'm guessing she
misinterpreted it they did not enjoy it
she did not enjoy it yeah nobody enjoyed
it in it yeah it was looked upon poorly
but to me it was like I'm just giving
you all I have you know
so
if yeah if I'm even able to text
correctly with a girl nowadays it's been
quite a story arc
um Malcolm Global thank you so much for
your time man
um for just being like a you know
someone that goes out as like a Seeker
in the world and is a curious person I
think we really need people like that
and
um it's been fascinating to kind of
witness uh some of your work over the
years and see how many of my friends
admire you and just to be able to sit
with you today and and think together
has been really cool thank you so much
thank you so much it's really fun thanks
[Music]
cause I must
I must don't
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel
it in my bones
[Music]